welcome back to the five we have some
very difficult news to report to you now
a former member of the five lost one of
his loved ones this weekend you of
course know Eric Bolling and his wife
Adrienne their beautiful son Eric chase
he passed away Friday in Colorado where
he was attending college he had just
started his sophomore year and he was
only 19 years old it's not clear yet how
he passed an autopsy will be performed
next week but in a post on Twitter Eric
said that he and Adrian are overwhelmed
by the love and support that they have
been receiving and they asked that you
please keep them in your prayers they
are in our prayers and the prayers of
the entire Fox News family Eric chase
brought so much love and joy to his
parents life if you watched our show
over the years you've probably heard
Eric proudly talk about his sweet son
was a baseball player like his dad
played left field he was an amazing
young man he did so much to help others
and he was an A student he excelled in
mathematics were very proud of him we
are truly heartbroken and we want to
extend our deepest condolences to the
bowling family Eric chase may he rest in
eternal peace just want to take a moment
to take it around the table to share
some of our reflections well you know I
know
Eric sat next Eric and I do not did not
know Eric chase but this I do know that
there's nothing harder than losing a son
a child and I just wanted to say to Eric
how much we pray for him and offer him
comfort Dana well I'm not an apparent
and one thing that I learned from him
was that that is the best part that was
the best part of Eric he was so
dedicated and I learned a lot about
selfless love from him and I'm silent I
I'm still blown away by this news and I
think if I feel this way I can't imagine
how okay they're feeling